jean françois corty merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors selon
une note de bercy on le disait la
production nationale et les importations
sont encore insuffisantes à ce stade
pour couvrir la totalité du besoin de
masquer le 11 mai avec cette donnée est
ce que c'est nécessaire selon vous de
repenser les mesures prévues pour le
déconfinement du 11 mai ce qui est exact
ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est un pari
d'avoir décidé que le 11 mai puisse être
une date pour le déconfinement parce
qu'on le sait et on est toujours dans
une logique de médecine de catastrophe
il ya toujours un nombre conséquent de
personnes qu'il faut soigner en
réanimation mais aussi en médecine de
ville avec un système de santé qui est
sous tension et puis une minute et du
collectif qui à -10% ça veut dire qu'il
reste beaucoup de gens qui
potentiellement pourront être infecté
avec des formes graves de la maladie
donc il va falloir un nombre de masques
conséquent énorme parce qu'évidemment il
ya une tension forte entre santé
publique libertés individuelles et
ratifié colonies qu'il va falloir
retourner travailler mais il ne faudra
pas sacrifier les personnes qui vont
être sur le terrain donc une tension
très forte et en fait ce qui est
important c'est que cette épidémie elle
va se combattre sur le terrain ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'il va falloir à les
dépister isoler les personnes qui seront
une suspecte et puis surtout conserver
les mesures barrières avoir des masques
pour se protéger il va falloir beaucoup
et c'est un fondamental pour réussir sur
les confinements et ne pas sacrifier un
pan de la population
alors justement sur cette question des
masques apparemment le stock serait
suffisant le 18 mai est ce que pour vous
il faut donc attendre au minimum cette
date pour amorcer le déconfinement alors
il ya une mesure politique a été prise
je vais pas revenir sur sa ce qu'il me
semble important aujourd'hui c'est que
il ne faut pas tout attendre de l'état
et on le sait sur beaucoup de crise
l'état pilote prend des décisions
majeures fait c'est comment dit on voit
bien qu'il ya un nombre important de
masquer besoins et qu'on va être en
tension sur de nombreux mois c'est qu'il
faut comprendre la matière
d'approvisionnement avant qu'on se
donner la capacité de produire nous
mêmes mais il faut aussi faire confiance
aux acteurs la société civile qui se
mobilisent
au niveau des élus locaux au niveau de
différentes personnes aux citoyens qui
fabrique des masques il va falloir
continuer cet effort s'appuyer sur des
tutoriels qui sont validées qui
permettent à chacun de pouvoir se défend
encore une fois ne pas tout attendre de
l'état dans une logique de survie c'est
fondamental dans ce contexte là
justement dans une logique de survie en
tant que professionnels de santé qu'est
ce que révèle pour vous cette
information à cette nouvelle information
sur la gestion des autorités concernant
la question du stock des masques on sait
depuis le début que la france mais tous
les pays y compris les pays du nord
riche n'était pas préparé à cette
épreuve là des mesures d'ajustement
structurel longue date qui fait que le
système de santé n'était pas prêt et
puis une politique de stocks notamment
des masques et qui était défaillante et
une incapacité à être indépendant en
matière de production de produits vitaux
que soient les masques certains
médicaments notamment qui va les voir à
considérer une nouvelle stratégie en
matière d'indépendance
et puis on voit on pilote à vue
aujourd'hui les autorités et puis les
autres ayant fonctionné voler sur des
critères épidémiologique et ses seins
qui dicte les modalités de déconfinement
par région par tranche d'âge par
catégorie professionnelle et c'est à ça
qu'il faut s'attendre dans les mois qui
viennent malheureusement c'est qu'on
paye aujourd'hui cache un manque de
préparation depuis plusieurs années
alors seul un l'académie de médecine
invite aujourd'hui à revêtir une
protection en tissu et ce dès maintenant
vous partagez cette recommandation on
sait qu'il va falloir utiliser tous les
outils nécessaires pour se protéger et
le masque est fondamental pour ne pas
transmettre la maladie dès lors qu'on
leur ait on serait porteur mais aussi
une certaine manière pour pas l'avoir
exploit falloir malgré tout respecter
les mesures barrières continuer à se
laver les mains est encore une fois
utilisé toutes les protections
nécessaires donc que ce soit le masque
classique chirurgicale que ce soit des
productions locales sur lesquels j'avais
un site en disant que qu'elles sont
fondamentales dans une logique de
pénurie doit falloir comme le dit d
académie comme le dit beaucoup d'autres
acteurs médicaux être vigilant
probablement systématisé dans tous les
lieux
la promiscuité je pense aux transports
en commun systématiser ces masques et
puis les rendre accessibles gérer
gratuitement il faut absolument qu'il
n'y ait aucune barrière à l'accès
financier pour ses masques
je fais confiance à nos concitoyens on a
vu qu'ils étaient respectueux de
confinement ils seront respectueux de
leur santé et de la santé les autres dès
lors qu'on leur met à disposition
facilement des masques pour vous un
masque à 5 euros maximum c'est trop cher
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est prévu 1 5
euro dans les bureaux de tabac ou dans
les pharmacies
moi je pense que c'est une erreur je
pense qu'il faut systématiser la
distribution vote aucun l'accès quasi
gratuit à des masses qu'il faut pas on
le sait les épidémies sont des
accélérateurs d'inégalités on sait que
les précaires en souffre beaucoup ne
faudrait pas qu'il y ait du fait de
contraintes financières une accentuation
de ces inégalités et parce qu'on n'a pas
les moyens de s'acheter hamas alors on
s'expose et on expose le reste de la
population
il faut tout faire la france a les
moyens financiers c'est la cinquième ou
sixième puissance économique mondiale a
les moyens de rendre accessible manière
inconditionnelle
ces masques qui vont être un outil
majeur dans le contrôle de l'épidémie
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup jean françois
corty d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste et ex directeur des
opérations internationales de médecins
du monde